[Música]
nos subimos a un carro blindado con un
guardaespaldas hasta el último momento
la dirección del encuentro se mantiene
en secreto porque el ex combatiente de
las farc con el que nos vamos a reunir
vive bajo medidas de alta seguridad
y ese día y su marido pasaron 30 años en
la selva como integrantes de la
guerrilla en 2016 la pareja firmó los
acuerdos de paz pero su pasado como
guerrilleros los persigue y tres años
después
yesenia presencia incidente el asesinato
de su marido cuando regresamos a la vida
civil éste fue su primer sombrero es era
mi esposo mi compañero mi amigo el 24 de
octubre del 2019
estábamos en la casa escuché unos
disparos
y cuando salí él estaba en el suelo que
el duro por ahí máximo cinco minutos
vivos
porque fueron 6 impactos en la espalda
este no es un caso aislado desde la
firma de los acuerdos de paz más de 270
ex combatientes han sido asesinados a
pesar de la promesa de protección del
gobierno tenerles sus cosas es una forma
de conservarlo y de no permitir que se
olvide porque resulta de que el problema
a veces es que los muertos se vuelven
números
volver una estadística las farc
desarmadas se han convertido en
objetivos en colombia una parte de la
población la sigue considerando
responsables de la guerra civil que
asoló el país durante más de 50 años
temáticos de cuatro firmantes de la paz
y en un ex integrante de ya la chs la
extinta fuera la dirigencia del partido
farc denunció lo que a ti
jon león es un abogado que defiende a ex
combatientes de las farc una de sus
clientes
astrid conde también fue ejecutada en la
calle en bogotá acepta volver a la
escena del crimen para explicarnos el
suceso pues va pasando por este lugar
según las investigaciones lo que dicen
es que hombres en una motocicleta de dos
hombres que venían a bordo de una
motocicleta pues uno de ellos desenfundó
una pistola y después descarga pues
contra el cuerpo de astrid la zona
aparentemente tranquila está en realidad
controlada por un grupo armado
jon nos permite estar diez minutos como
máximo en el lugar y tres guardaespaldas
lo acompañan el abogado nunca ha luchado
por la guerrilla pero como defiende a
las farc también está amenazado de
muerte
está pagando 80 millones de pesos
para la persona pues que me mate
como una recompensa algo junto a jon
andrés parís un antiguo miembro de alto
rango de las farc para el el gobierno
colombiano no ha cumplido con sus
compromisos es el equipo de escoltas que
estamos obligados a
y aportar y que es el resultado también
de la cuerda de la habana estamos ante
la eventualidad de ser asesinado o ya
sea amenazas generales a todos los
combatientes que firmamos la paz como
estaba previsto abandonamos rápidamente
la zona las ciudades no son lugares
seguros para los ex combatientes tras
entregar las armas la mayoría fueron
reubicados en campos alejados de la
sociedad
perdido en las montañas hay que conducir
cinco horas desde bogotá para llegar al
campamento de con 11 nos contactamos con
un exguerrillero que acepta recibirnos
harley se unió la guerrilla a los 15
años después de toda una vida en la
selva el regreso a la vida civil fue
brutal
estuvo tanto tiempo en mi caso 31 años
en armas que era lo que vemos nosotros
había una dirección que es la de los
planes y todo orden y hay para abajo la
cumplíamos
entonces ahora tenemos que pensar
elaborar nuestro nuestro nuestro futuro
en su casa guardo recuerdos de su
antigua vida como combatiente bueno de
regreso a mi casa me siento feliz
ya que ha sido mi hogar durante cuatro
años
la macheta la veremos todavía que está
esta funda la fabricamos nosotros mismos
noche desarrollas no no tenemos armas la
arma que la tenemos la tribu acá que es
el arma ideológica es decir no
entregamos a nadie el gobierno paga
cerca de 250 dólares a todos los ex
combatientes que viven en los
campamentos lo que supone el 90 por
ciento del salario mínimo colombiano
para ganar un poco más algunos trabajan
y sufriendo con los destructivos por ahí
vamos bien después de salir de la
guerrilla y ahí se convirtió en
agricultor este país con 900 mil pesos
realmente no sé divinamente ganó
alcanzaron a una lógica por eso se
advirtió a mí me gusta el campo y pero
me decidió comenzar a producir para ver
si por un otro medio puedo subsistir
porque es que realmente es un alcance
para nada
en cuanto a la ley tuvo que abandonar el
campo para trabajar en una cervecería de
bogotá después de 31 años en la selva
luchando para la guerrilla el ex
combatiente tuvo que aprender a vivir de
nuevo en la ciudad
la mayoría de los empleados son antiguos
soldados de las farc compartieron sus
ahorros e hicieron cursos de formación
para fabricar cerveza y tres años
después abrieron la cervecería claro me
gusta el trabajo de la de la fabricación
de la cerveza pues me gustan todos los
trabajos porque la cultura me ha sido
trabajador cultura cultura o adriana
siempre se buscó en el trabajo
y aunque ar ley le va bien no todos los
ex miembros de las farc han tenido tanta
suerte muchos de ellos han perdido toda
esperanza de reintegración más de dos
mil ex guerrilleros habrían vuelto a
tomar las armas desde los acuerdos de
paz en beneficio de los disidentes de
las farc que están recuperando su poder
en colombia
[Música]